aha aha what's up reject nation you know
what Martin Lawrence the next trailer
for bad boys for life before they
rebooted with two women
starring Tiffany Haddish and Leslie
Jones there you go / can't wait for that
one also called bad boys yeah yeah of
course this movie's gonna end with them
handing off the keys to Will Smith's car
yeah tossing them cool yesh and
everyone's gonna applaud it that much
but listen guys before we go into this I
want to thank thank you to everyone
who's been following us at our patreon
page showing your support your
contribution I just watch The Addams
Family Resource a over there we do
weekly q and A's and then we also do TV
show reaction stream along sync up with
the time code and those shows are agents
of shield caught ham haunting of Hell
House s1 Cobra cos season two stranger
things season three and then there are
shows would reduce stream alongs but we
also have reaction highlights included
so we edited down ten minutes worth of
footage included for the whole reaction
so you doesn't worry about syncing up
and those shows are super natural Hunter
hunter Death Note Code Geass just
continued my hero academia this week we
also covered the movie not long ago Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood one punch
man attack on Titan and he does music
video reactions weekly hey this is a
Sony trailer I mean there's probably
using it here so we're gonna be
demonetized so go up to our patreon page
there's some support
whoa you've Suicide Squad it's a
reference
[Music]
believe that
oh no high school musical Vanessa
oh it's personal the shot suicides what
there are so many references
ooh they chopped his head off
John wick three
damn you take that helicopter down ya
see 1,000 everything boy that looks
great exactly it looks very self-aware
yeah there's a lot of references man
flat-out says High School Musical when
we're cutting in Vanessa Hudgens he'll a
Batman references Batman Suicide Squad
hence the shirt I'm wearing well looky
there yup yup I'm here to service the
fans not fanservice it's a quote from
Tim Miller I don't know if it's a
reference he said suicide I'm just gonna
assume that's all reference I'm gonna
read in everything yeah we're trying to
transition into the new rock stars
channels so as many Easter eggs as we
can point out as possible well Mark
Lawrenson Will Smith or in this trailer
and they're also in the first two bad
boys movies that which is the reference
yeah it could be directly linked is what
we're thinking right now and I think it
comes is the third like in the
chronology it's the last one oh this
looks awesome
I know Michael Bay's not returning for
this this still seems in the vein of his
kind of style but two trailers
back-to-back that seem to all have the
same kind of tone in spirit and energy I
love this stuff work that we're seeing
here there's some obvious CG like the
helicopter crash or whatever but it
looks like there's still relying of as
much practicality whether it's action
scenes as possible with this trailer has
confirmed that this is gonna be a hard
are excited about yeah yeah I feel like
I mean there you never say never and
everything gets to a point where it can
be pg-13 but I feel like a bad boys
pg-13 would just not be what people want
and it's a it's more personal because
someone was trying to kill Wilson after
Mike so Martin Lawrence has to come out
of retirement or whatever they never
retire do you know my god too old for
this [__]
he's getting to become he's Murtagh you
know this is yeah I like the trailer a
lot de I mean like the first trailer I
thought was kind of fine and they're not
very different altogether but this one
actually grabbed me and I wasn't even
thinking about Michael Bay or anything
like that I was just sort of swept up in
the yeah the chemistry and the fun of
the action and stuff like that and it
looks like it has the two essential
ingredients for bad boys which is you
know like big yeah neon action and then
you know Martin Lawrence and Will
Smith's chemistry Will Smith needs a hit
man he needs a hit right now maybe this
could be it
why cuz just everything he's doing has
been killing it but not enough killing
it you know like Gemini man huge success
could have been a huge or success so I
mean Aladdin just made a billion dollars
that's right that's right that's right
[Laughter]
yeah I think as long as this film it's
like a fifty to sixty percent on Rotten
Tomatoes for critics got a pretty good
chance of you know getting a high
audience score and this looks like it's
gonna deliver like the bad boys films
need to be exceptional filmmaking may be
exactly what this trailer is advertising
fun action movies good chemistry to be a
good chemistry really funny competent
action scenes it looks like that one
scene the in the daylight with the
Porsche like most advertised car chase
scene in here it just kept cutting back
to it from the beginning to the very
faith in this was like it's all blast
you're forgetting the most important
part it needs to be two hours and 50
minutes if if we're gonna have an
authentic badboys experience
John bad boys to two hours and 26
minutes what oh sorry that's that's a
big different think I'm exactly right
about that oh yeah you know you count
I've seen you watch movies do you think
they'll play the bad boys for life
soundtrack in here hopefully maybe
they'll just recycle the entire thing
clear the same cell and save that money
alright guys what are you excited for
bad boys for life you think they should
have D aged Martin Lawrence for no
reason subscriber the real rejects click
that notification bell and hey I would
like to give a patron of the day
shoutouts
a man named Tyler hey christmas is
coming up soon and you know what buddy
I'm hoping that you could be my Santa
Claus and that way I could sit on your
lap and you could be like have you been
a bad boy
this Christmas that would be like Oh
Santa I've been a naughty boy and then
you're gonna be like that's not what I
asked you I asked if you've been a bad
boy not a naughty boy I'm like oh I'm
sorry I misread the situation and then
you're gonna give me some coal and tell
me to leave
yeah then you'll learn a valuable lesson
and all thanks to Tyler's wisdom and his
generosity you know cuz that's the kind
of guy Tyler is and I guess in this
scenario metaphor I'm Martin Lawrence
well you're not Bob oh you're just
you're just here for your look ah okay
I'm one of the chicks in this